PROFESSOR: An
elementary idea that
gets you a long way
in counting things
is this idea of counting with
bijections, which is counting
one thing by counting another.
And we can illustrate
that by example.
Let's begin with looking
at some stuff that
is easy to count using just the
simple sum and product rules.
So suppose that I'm
trying to count passwords.
This is a contrived,
over-simplified example,
but it gives you the idea.
And this is what I
mean by a password.
A password is a sequence of
characters that are either
letters or digits subject
to the constraints
that they are supposed
to be between six
and eight characters long.
They're supposed to
start with a letter,
and they're case sensitive.
So you can tell the difference
between uppercase and lowercase
letters.
So let's define the set L of
all the letters-- uppercase
and lowercase together.
And let D be the set of
digits from 0 through 9.
Then we said that
passwords are supposed
to be between six
and eight words long,
but it's a little bit easier
actually to just use links
as a parameter.
So let's think about
words of length n
that satisfy the
password conditions.
So Pn is going to
be the length n
words starting with a letter,
which is one of the password
constraints.
So we can express
that has a length n
word can be broken up into
the first character, which
is an L, paired with
the rest of the word--
the remaining n
minus 1 characters.
And the remaining n minus
1 characters can be either
L's or D's.
So though length n
passwords can be expressed
as the product of L with the
n-th power of L union D-- that
is, L union D cross
L union D cross
L union D, n minus 1 times.
Well, now we have an
easy way to count this,
because the size of this
product by the product rule
is the size of L times
the size of L union
D to the n minus first power.
And of course, L union D,
since letters and digits
don't overlap by the sum
rule, the size of them
is just L plus D. And so
I get this nice formula
that is 52 letters
times 52 letters
plus 10 digits raised to
the n minus first power.
What about the passwords?
Well, the passwords were
then P6 union P7 union P8.
And since words of
length six don't
overlap with words of
length seven or eight,
this is a disjoint union.
And therefore, the total number
of passwords as specified
is simply the size of
P6 plus the size P7
plus the size of P8.
There's the formula
when I plug in.
And it turns out to be a
good size number, 19 times 10
to the 14th.
That's one simple
example where I'm
translating a spec into because
something that I can express
easily as a products and
disjoint sums of stuff
that I already know the size of.
Let's just do another example.
Suppose that I want to count
the number of 4-digit numbers.
So the elements of
these 4-digit numbers
are 0 through 9-- there are 10
possibilities-- with at least
one 7-- the number of 4-digit
sequences of digits that
have at least one 7 in them.
And one way to
count is I can make
it a sum of different
4-digit numbers containing
one 7, depending on
where the first 7 is.
If there's at least one
7, there's a first 7.
That's the well-ordering
principle applied.
So if we let x
abbreviate any digit--
there are 10 possible
values of x-- and o
represent any digit
other than 7-- so there's
nine possible values of o--
then the words that start with 7
can then be followed
with any three digits.
So 7xxx is one possible pattern
when the first occurrence of 7
is first.
Another possible pattern is
when you have a digit that's
not 7 followed by a 7.
This is when 7 occurs second
followed by anything at all.
Likewise, here 7 occurs third,
and here, 7 occurs forth.
Now, these individual
patterns are easy enough
to count using the product
rule, because here, I
have to count how many triples
of any digits are there.
Well, there's 10 digits,
so it's 10 cubed.
Here, how many
sequences of where
the first choice is 9 and the
second two choices are 10.
And it's 9 times 10 squared.
Here, it's 9 squared times 10.
And here it's 9 cubed.
These are disjoint,
because they're
distinguished by where
the first 7 occurs.
And so I just add them up.
And I get this number.
It's not especially
interesting, but it's 3,439.
So that's an exercise
in counting something
by somewhat ingeniously
breaking it up
into a sum of
disjoint things that
are themselves easier to count.
There's another way that's
another standard trick that
comes up in
combinatorics of how do
you count the sequence
of 4-digit numbers
with at least one 7, by
counting the complement.
Count the numbers
of 4-digit numbers
that don't have
any 7's and simply
subtract that number, the number
of 4-digit numbers with no 7's,
from the total number
of 4-digit numbers.
And that's going to
be the numbers that
are left over that have one 7.
Now, the number of 4-digit
numbers is easy to count.
And it will turn out that
the number of 4-digit numbers
with no 7's is also
really easy to count,
because the number of 4-digit
numbers is 10 to the fourth
and the number of 4-digit
numbers with no 7's,
there's nine possible choices
for each of the remaining
digits.
So it's just the
digits 0 through 9,
leaving out 7, to the fourth
power, or 9 to the fourth.
And you can double check
that 10 to the fourth minus 9
to the fourth is 3,4,39.
So now, with that practice
using the basic sum and product
rules, we can start
applying and thinking
about the bijection rule.
So the bijection
rule simply says
that if I have a bijection
between two sets A and B,
then they have the
same size, at least
assuming that they
are finite sets.
And the only kind of things
we're counting are finite sets.
Let's use an example
of that, where
I'm going to count the
number of subsets of a set A
by finding a bijection
between the subsets of a set A
and something that I
do know how to count.
In fact, we've
already counted them,
the binary strings
of a given length.
What's the bijection?
Well, suppose that A
is a set of n elements,
call them a1 through an.
And I have some arbitrary
subset of A. Say, it's got a1,
and it doesn't have a2, and
it has a3, and it has a4,
and it doesn't have a5.
And then it's got some
selection of the other numbers.
And it turns out
it has a n in it.
Well, if I think of
a subset laid out
this way up against the
corresponding elements in A,
I can code this
in an obvious way
by putting a 1 where the
element is in the subset and a 0
where the element is
not in the subset.
In effect, this is the so-called
characteristic function
of the subset where 1 means
that that index element-- a 1
in the i-th position
means that ai is there.
And a 0 in the i-th position
means that ai is not there.
So the second
coordinate here is a 0.
That means a2 is not there.
And this is easily
seen to be a bijection.
That is, given the string,
you could figure out
what the subset is.
Given the subset, you can figure
out what the unique string is.
So we have a bijection.
And what we conclude
then is that the number
of n-bit strings is equal to
the size of power set of A.
It's equal to the
number of subsets of A.
And of course, we
know how to count
the number of n-bit strings.
It's 2 to the n.
So what we just figured out
is, if I have a set of size n,
it's got 2 to the n subsets.
And a slick way to say
that without mentioning
n is that the size
of the power set of A
is simply 2 the size of A.
One more example of
bijection counting
that is kind of
fun and interesting
will illustrate the fact
that we learn something
by finding a bijection,
even if we don't know
how to count either one yet.
So what I'm interested
in is, suppose
I have a situation
where there are
five kinds of doughnuts-- five
different flavors of doughnuts.
And I want to sort
of select a dozen.
Now, I want to know how
many selections there are.
So for example-- these little
O's represent doughnuts--
I might choose a
selection of a dozen
by choosing two chocolate
and no lemon-- I
don't like those so much--
and six sugars and two
glazed and two plain.
So there are 12 doughnuts
here using four out
of the five possible
flavors of doughnuts.
This is what I'll call a
selection of a doughnut.
And I'd like to know how many
such selections of doughnuts
are there.
Well, let that be the set A, the
set of all these different ways
of selecting 12 doughnuts
when there are five
flavors of doughnuts available.
Well, this is, again, an obvious
correspondence between the set
A of doughnut selections and the
set B of 0's and 1's of length
16 that contain four 1's.
What's the correspondence?
Well, here's my
doughnut selection.
And of course, the reason why I
use those O's for doughnuts is
that they also
correspond to 0's.
I can just put in
1's as delimiters
between the groups of flavors.
So after the chocolate
doughnuts, I put a 1.
And then after the
lemon doughnuts,
that happen to be
none, I put another 1.
And then after the six
sugar doughnuts, I put a 1.
And then I kind of consolidate
and I extract from the doughnut
selection this 16-bit
word with 12 0's
corresponding to 12
doughnuts and four 1's
corresponding to breaking up
those groups of 0's into five
categories, five
slots, corresponding
to the number of
doughnuts of each flavor.
So the general
bijection, of course,
is that if I have a selection
of c chocolate doughnuts,
l lemon doughnuts, s
sugar doughnuts, g glazed,
and p plain of
any number really,
a selection of doughnuts with
this number of chocolates,
lemons, glazed, plain
corresponds to a binary word
with c plus l plus s plus
g plus p 0's and four 1's.
And so what we can
say is that the set
of 16-digit words with four
1's is exactly the same size
as the number of
doughnut selections,
even though at this
moment we don't
know how to count either one.
We will see in the next lecture
an easy way to count the number
of those 16-bit
words with four 1's.
But for now, our conclusion
from bijection counting
is that these two sets are
the same size, even though I
haven't counted yet either one.